how's it going everybody maxwell mcgee
here for another gamespot news update
where ubisoft has just announced that
Ghost Recon online will launch april
10th on PC as Ghost Recon phantoms after
over a year in open beta along with the
name change Ubisoft promises complete
reworking of lighting and level design
on the majority of maps besides the
graphical glitter Ghost Recon phantoms
will include a new narrative layer based
on a group of X ghosts called the
phantom described on the official
website as faceless ghost killers not to
be confused with the infamous ghostface
killah there are also major changes
coming to the games matchmaking and
customization skills Ubisoft said
matchmaking will now take into account
both the skill and gear which will grant
a fair gaming experience to all users
both new and veterans paying or not the
team is also going to reveal the new mod
master a weapon camo system which will
allow countless customization
possibilities if you participated in the
ghost recon online beta no need to worry
about losing your stats as Ubisoft
promises our current players will not
have to start over and if you're one of
the 5 million people out there he's been
playing ghost recon online this past
year this should come as a welcome
announcement and for more updates on
everything ghost recon be sure to head
on over to gamespot.com